chaque assemblée parlementaire puisse
améliorer le texte malgré tout nous
avons constaté au fil des jours une
volonté caractérisée et systématique des
groupes de position de gauche de
procéder à de l'obstruction
l'obstruction comment avec des dizaines
d'amendements identiques déposés pour
supprimer tel ou tel article
habituellement un groupe dépose un
amendement de suppression c'est légitime
mais là ils étaient déposés à 70 80 90
exemplaires avec autant d'explications
de votes nous avons vu fleurir des
sous-amendements déposés en cour de
débat pour par exemple demander que
lorsque un amendement demande au
gouvernement de remettre un rapport sur
un sujet ou un autre pour le premier
février 2024 il est sous un moment
proposé de décaler cette remise de
rapport au 2 février aux 3 février au 4
février jusque à tenir sur deux mois ou
trois mois uniquement pour gagner du
temps nous avons vu des séries
d'amendements je pense à une série du
groupe écologiste avec 140 140
amendements tous répétitifs qui ont tous
été défendus qui ont été expliqués et
puis au bout de plusieurs dizaines de
minutes de débats ils ont tous été
retirés par le groupe écologiste la
seule était de faire perdre du temps et
puis depuis hier nous entendons des
sénateurs et des sénatrices des groupes
de gauche nous expliquer et dire
clairement dans l'hémicycle ça a été dit
ce matin par le groupe communiste que
leur seul objectif c'est de retarder de
retarder pour empêcher le Sénat de se
prononcer et de dire sa position sur le
texte et le gouvernement agit à la fois
en voulant accélérer un certain nombre
de discussions tout en gardant la
possibilité de débattre du fond et le
gouvernement agit aussi puisque la
Constitution s'est démocratique c'est
notre texte constitutionnel nous
autorise à prendre un certain nombre de
disposition pour demander au Sénat de se
prononcer par un vote unique sur
l'ensemble du texte l'ensemble du texte
tel qu'il était adopté jusqu'à présent
jusqu'à l'article 9 l'ensemble du texte
pour les articles qui suivent avec en
plus les amendements que auquel le
gouvernement donne un avis favorable
notre objectif est très clair c'est la
clarté du débat nous pensons qu'il est
normal que le Sénat puisse voter sur ce
texte nous pensons qu'il est normal que
les groupes politiques et sénateurs
puissent dire leur position parce que
c'est aussi une question de clarté et de
transparence pour les Français
syndicat qui était le temps du débat ont
le temps du débat au Parlement il a été
un petit peu
un petit peu forcé aujourd'hui par
d'autres par votre article 44-3 et
surtout est-ce que ça veut dire que le
président a fermé la porte au syndicat
la porte est close finalement de
l'Élysée alors qu'on me faisait qu'elle
serait toujours ouverte il y a eu un
temps de conservation avec les
organisations syndicales les
organisations patronales de la durée 4
mois et il était riche puisque sur la
question des retraites progressives sur
la question de l'emploi des seniors sur
la question des carrières longues de la
pénibilité ou du minimum de pension nous
avons amélioré notre texte nous l'avons
enrichi nous avons tenu compte de
beaucoup des demandes des partenaires
sociaux qu'ils soient organisations
syndicales ou organisation patronales
cette concertation évidemment n'a pas
permis de lever tous les désaccords
notamment sur la question de l'âge mais
elle a permis d'avancer après ce long
temps de concertation qui vient après 4
ans de débat public sur la question des
retraites nous sommes dans un temps
parlementaire l'assemblée a été empêchée
par la France insoumise par les groupes
de gauche d'aller au terme de ce débat
et le Sénat aurait pu l'être aussi et
donc nous sommes dans ce temps
parlementaire ça n'empêche pas de
continuer à discuter ça n'empêche pas de
continuer à parler la première ministre
l'a dit le mystère du travail est donc
moi-même comme
au bout de 18 heures de débat sur la loi
de sécurisation professionnelle ou
l'article 44-3 avait été évoqué pour
paramètres et demander au Sénat à votre
unique donc il n'y a pas de de brimade
il n'y a pas de limite posée au débat
parlementaire nous sommes dans le
respect des procédures le respect de la
Constitution il y a vraiment avec une
volonté très très claire qui est de
permettre une clarté dans l'expression
des forces politiques l'expression ici
des sénateurs demain des députés sur ce
texte est un texte important
le président le Président le
gouvernement gouverne ce qui a été
rappelé il a répondu ce matin nos
organisations syndicales en rappelant
l'importance qu'avait eu la concertation
l'importance aussi de son attention au
sujet qui était porté tout comme ce sont
les temps sur la mobilisation
ministre une question pour Mediapart
est-ce que vous connaissez le montant
moyen de la retraite d'un sénateur d'une
sénatrice
est-ce que ça vous paraît normal
séparation des pouvoirs qui fait que la
retraite des parlementaires et décider
pour les députés par le Bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale pour les sénateurs
par le Bureau du Sénat je suis membre du
gouvernement respectueux de la
séparation du pouvoir donc je vous
invite à vous rapprocher du Sénat
est-ce que vous pensez là on les compte
sont très très justes pour avoir un vote
à la majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
est-ce qu'un 49 toit est envisagé avec
la première ministre notre objectif est
d'avoir une majorité sur ce texte
majorité au Sénat une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale nous travaillons
nous avançons nous avons entendu un
certain nombre de propositions de
l'opposition évidemment nous avons
entendu des propositions du groupe
républicain c'est ce que nous avons fait
ici avec une meilleure prise en compte
des trimestres à qui au titre de
l'accueil d'un enfant que sur la
maternité ou l'adoption c'est le
principe de la surcote nous entendons
des demandes sur les transitions
notamment sur les questions de retraite
progressive de transition pour l'emploi
des seniors le Sénat a voté contre la
vie du gouvernement d'ailleurs un CDI
senior ma producteur il faut que nous
puissions continuer à parler à
l'Assemblée nous avons aussi entendu un
certain nombre de demandes et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le Sénat la voté
nous sommes prêts nous allons nous
allons créer des apporter des
modifications à dispositif de carrière
longue pour prendre en compte ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler avant 21 ans
donc nous allons continuer à avancer à
construire étape par étape avec toujours
une volonté très claire celle d'avoir
une majorité sur le texte